[Music]
tonight we are learning a bit more about
the victims killed in that
tragic highway crash on thursday thank
you for joining us
at six i'm brian loftis and i'm kirsten
joyce
the victims come from a tight-knit
cycling community which is still of
course
reeling from this tragedy their names
released by the clark county coroner's
office tonight they include
39 year old aaron ray 57 year old
michael murray
48 year old eskoy ahmet 57 year old
thomas
traeger and 41-year-old gerard nieva
the crash happened thursday morning in
between boulder city and searchlight
when a box truck collided with the group
of cyclists and their support vehicle on
the freeway
a news now reporter madison kimbrell on
this story live from
university medical center with how the
community is coming together
following this tragedy
yeah one of the cyclists injured was
airlifted here to umc
trauma in trauma in critical condition
now cyclists all around the community
here in las vegas are really rallying
together
to do as much as they can to help as
much as they can
take a look at the video that we shot
where you can see the extent of the
scene
four men and one woman died yesterday
after a box truck that was driving in
the same direction
as the group of cyclists veered into
their lane killing and injuring several
riders this happened on u.s 95 south of
boulder highway at mile marker 35.
as of now we know that three people are
injured but we don't know the status
at this time two were transported
immediately to the hospital
that's according to the nhp trooper that
was on scene
the other person injured did not seem to
have life-threatening injuries
fellow cyclist friend and former metro
police officer michael anderson was
there yesterday
and shared some words we do this nipton
loop every year
no problems
this year we just
just in the wrong places a long time
anderson created this gofundme page for
his friends and on it he lists the names
of the cyclists who lost their lives
along with those that are still fighting
he says the main purpose of the gofundme
page is to ease some of the financial
strain the families may be going through
right now
if you are interested in contributing to
that gofundme page we have a link
up on our website of course we'll keep
you updated on this story
as more information comes through
reporting live from umc
madison kimbrough 8 news now